welcome to the dynamic world of devops
where Automation and efficiency reign
supreme in this thrilling tutorial by
simply learn we will embark on a journey
through the realm of scripting languages
the ansung heroes of devops imagine
having a power to orchestrate complex
tasks streamline deployments and Conquer
infrastructure management with just a
few lines of code scripting languages
are your trustworthy allies in this epic
adventure enabling you to automate
optimize and revolutionalize your devops
workflows whether you're a Season Pro or
a curious nowi get ready to unlock the
secrets of python bash and more and
supercharge your devops game like never
before that said if these are the type
of videos you'd like to watch then hit
that subscribe button and the bell icon
to get notified and if you're a
professional with a minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring devops
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program in
devops from Caltech University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
course Link in the description box below
now without further delay let's get
started devops for short development and
operations is a set of practices and
principles that aim to bridge the gap
between software development velopment
and it operations it's a cultural and
Technical M that focuses on
collaboration Automation and continuous
Improvement to deliver high quality
software faster and more reliable
scripting languages play a pivotal role
in devops for several reasons let's go
through a few of them firstly automation
devops is all about automating
repetitive tasks in software development
and deployment life cycle scripting
languages such as python bash Ruby and
Powershell provide the tools needed to
write scripts that automate various
processes from provisioning
infrastructure to configuring servers
and deploying applications next
flexibility scripting languages are
versatile and can be used across
different platforms and Technologies
this flexibility allows devops
professionals to create custom Solutions
tailored to their specific needs
integrating various tools and services
seamlessly now the third Point
infrastructure as code or IAC IAC is a
fundamental Concept in devops enabling
infrastructure provisioning and
management through code scripting
languages are essential for creating and
maintaining IAC scripts that Define and
deploy infrastructure resources in
repeatable and consistent manner fourth
Point tool integration devops relies on
a wide range of tools for tasks like
Version Control continuous integration
containerization and orchestration and
Etc scripting languages are often used
to write scripts that interact with
these tools facilitating smooth
integration and workflow automation now
the fifth Point monitoring and Reporting
scripting languages are crucial for
building monitoring and Reporting
Solutions devops professionals can use
scripts to collect data from various
sources analyze it and generate reports
to monitor system health and performance
now the sixth Point troubleshooting and
debugging when issue arises in devops
environment scripting languages can be
invaluable for quickly diagnosing the
problems making own the fight changes
and implementing fixes now the last
point the learning curve many scripting
languages are relatively easy to learn
making them accessible to a wide range
of professionals this accessibility
encourages collaboration between
development and operations team and a
core devops principle in summary
scripting languages are essential for
devops experts because they provide the
means to automate customize and
orchestrate various aspects of software
development and delivery pip L Mastery
of scripting languages empowers devops
professionals to build efficient
scalable and resilient systems
ultimately contributing to the success
of their organizations in the fast based
world of modern software development so
far we have understood the importance of
scripting languages for devops now we
will look into the top 10 scripting
languages to learn for devops but before
we continue in the session let's hear
from our Learners about their personal
experience and their success story after
getting graduated from the devops
postgraduate program from Caltech
offered by simply learn I started my It
Journey with Accenture 3 years ago I
joined there as a cloud architect there
I worked with AWS and Azure Technologies
I was anyway looking for higher paying
job and devops seemed the right career
choice so I decided to go with the
postgraduate programming devops in
collaboration with Caltech CME course
was divided into modules and we had
assignments
I was really impressed by how many job
interviews I landed after I added the
certification to my portfolio and now I
am earning 40% more than my previous job
didn't only boost my career but also my
confidence feeling inspired already
consider checking the devops
postgraduate program offered by simply
laan from Caltech University in
collaboration with IBM for more details
use the link in the description box
below now let's proceed with a brief
disc description of each of these
scripting languages on our list and
their importance in the context of
devops starting with python python is a
pous in devops due to its Simplicity and
versatility its vast Library ecosystem
including libraries tools like anible
and puppet make it ideal for automation
configuration management and scripting
Python's reliability also promotes
collaboration amongst devops teams now
the next one Java Java through primarily
known as a compiled language is used in
devops for its robustness in building
server side applications and tools it's
common for building plugins and
extensions for various devops platforms
enhancing their functionality moving
ahead we have JavaScript JavaScript is
essentially for devops especially in the
context of web applications and cloud
services it's crucial for creating
automation scripts within web browsers
managing Cloud resources through AWS
Lambda and controlling various aspects
of web- based infrastructures the fourth
one is PHP PHP is often used in devops
for web related tasks such as managing
web servers and web application
deployments it can be particularly handy
for scripting tasks involving web
services and apis the next one in the
list is Ruby ru's concise syntax and
Rich library of germs make it valuable
for devops scripting chef and puppet two
popular configuration management tools
are written in Ruby making it integral
for infrastructure automation now the
sixth one is Scala Scala compatibility
with Java libraries and functional
programming capabilities are
advantageous in devops it can be used
for building scalable and efficient
tools for managing and orchestrating
cloud-based infrastructure the next one
in the list is goang or go goang is
becoming increasingly popular in devops
due to its efficiency and simplicity it
excels in building microservices
container orchestration tools like
kubernetes and various Cloud related
utilities thanks to its small binary
sizes and fast execution the next one on
the list is cotlin while cotlin is known
for Android app development it can also
be used for devops tasks its conciseness
and interoperability with Java libraries
make it suitable for writing automation
scripts especially when transforming or
transitioning from java environment now
the next one in the list is typescript
typescript an extension of JavaScript is
crucial for enhancing code quality and
maintainability in devops it's employed
in developing web-based automation tools
and managing Cloud infrastructure with a
strong emphasis on type safety and now
the last one swift primarily known for
IOS app development is emerging in the
devops world due to its speed and safety
features it can be used to create
utilities for iOS based infrastructure
management and automation tasks in Mac
OS environments each of these scripting
languages bring unique strengths and
capabilities to the devops toolkit
allowing professionals to choose the
best fit language for their specific
Automation and infrastructure management
needs now before we end the video if you
are a professional with minimum one year
of experience and an aspiring devops
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading realtime experts then search no
more simply learns professional
certification program in devops from IIT
guati should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below also if you're an
aspiring devops engineer looking for
online training and certifications in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns master
program and devops should be your right
choice for more details use the link in
the description box below and with that
we have reached the end of the session
on scripting languages for devops should
you need any assistance regarding PP and
other resources that we used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts we'll be more than happy to
resolve your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you and keep
learning stay tuned for more from Simply
learn staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click click here to watch
similar videos to ner up and get
certified click
here